PROFESSOR: So the transfer
of respiratory pathogens
is primarily accomplished
through droplets
that are emitted by
an infected person
and then either breathed
in or ending up on surfaces
and touched and incorporated
into the body in some other way
by a susceptible person.
So let's begin by talking
about the formation of droplets
during respiration.
So these droplets can
form in different parts
of the respiratory tract.
So the respiratory tract
refers to the whole system
of your breathing
apparatus in your body.
So that includes, of
course, your lungs,
which involves a
network of passages
going from the large bronchus
down to the bronchioles
and ultimately to the alveolar
sacs where the air is exchanged
or oxygen gets into the
blood and carbon dioxide
is picked up, and
then you exhale.
In the upper respiratory
tract, we have of course
the mouth and the nose
and the larynx, the voice
box where sounds are made.
The nasopharynx is
sort of the region
behind the mouth
and the nose where
the passages are connected.
And in all of those
different regions
of the respiratory tract,
when we breathe in,
air is coming through
in one direction,
and of course when we
exhale, it's coming back out.
And there is a lot of
fluid in the lungs.
So the airways are
lined typically
with surfactant film
and mucus, which
is a thick substance
we're all familiar with.
It can vary in composition
but generally has
some large macromolecules
and in particular proteins
that are called
mucins, which give it
it's sort of thick consistency.
There are also ions such as
sodium and chloride, which
are dissolved in the liquid.
And even liquid such
as saliva in your mouth
have a similar composition but
less of the sort of thick mucin
proteins that I mentioned
compared to the deeper
parts the respiratory tract.
Of course, when
someone gets sick,
also there can be more of
the sort of mucus and phlegm
that's generated to help the
body deal with the pathogen.
So all those liquids
and fluids are
present in different parts
of the respiratory tract.
And so there are a number of
mechanisms which are still
subject to scientific
research and debate by which
droplets are created
and ultimately emitted
when a person is breathing out.
So let's begin by thinking
about such processes
in the upper respiratory tract.
So in the upper
respiratory tract,
we can imagine, first of
all, that the passages have
a little bit larger spacing.
So for example, your mouth
might be open by centimeters
or millimeters.
If you go into
your nose, there's
of course various hairs and
smaller structures which
are often covered with mucus
and liquids, which as the air
is passing by, could be leading
to some breakup of droplets.
And then of course also in
the voicebox and other areas
of the upper respiratory tract.
So the main mechanism here
for generating droplets
would be the breakup of
viscoelastic filaments
in a fluid flow.
So another word for
breakup is fragmentation
of viscoelastic filaments.
And by that, I mean that the
mucus especially is a fluid.
So it has a viscosity, a
resistance to shear flow.
But it also can have
some elasticity.
If you pull on it, it can
pull back a little bit
because there are these
macromolecules present.
So in general, we have a
somewhat complicated reality
of that liquid or that fluid.
And a filament
refers to the fact
that those droplets
can be stretched out,
and as the air is then
blowing past those filaments,
it can start to break up.
So this is our basic mechanism.
And this is mainly
going to be happening
while a person is exhaling, at
least in terms of emissions.
It's also possible
when you Inhale,
there'll be some of
those droplets created.
They go into your lungs or
get deposited on the surfaces
and then manage to somehow
come back out again.
But certainly during exhaling,
you would imagine more--
or you could see actually that
more droplets are created.
So if we think of
some examples of that,
we might have, for example,
when I'm speaking or breathing
and my mouth is a
little bit open,
if I imagine drawing kind
of let's say a person's lips
and mouth might look
something like this.
So I'm kind of
exaggerating here,
but of course there's
saliva present,
and there may be little
filaments that form.
Of course, we can see this.
And then as we're inhaling, and
especially as we're exhaling,
then these filaments will kind
of bend and they can break,
and some of them
will be emitted.
And in fact, these have
been recently visualized
in great detail.
And anyway, so
that's one mechanism.
So it's these
filaments of saliva
in this case could
be forming around--
I'll just mention
this picture might
be, for example, the mouth.
We could also look at
the act of speaking.
We will discuss in detail
later in this course
that the emissions of
infectious droplets
is very strongly correlated
with vocalization.
If you're speaking,
there's many more emissions
than when you're just
simply breathing,
and when you're speaking
in a louder volume
or when you're singing,
that rate of emission
goes up very significantly.
So there's clearly emissions
related to the vocal--
the voicebox and to the
vocal folds in the glottis,
which is basically the voicebox.
So what that looks like is if
you take kind of a side view,
there are these--
as a cross-sectional
view, there's
these folds where the
air is flowing through,
let's say, in this direction.
And these are kind
of waving together.
They're vibrating where
the frequency could
be, for example,
100 hertz depending
on the tone of your speech
and the type of vowels
you're making or other sounds.
And again, what we
have is that some here
are saying this might
be in the glottis.
This could be the vocal folds.
And this is basically
the voicebox,
is more colloquial term.
And as the air is
flowing through there,
this part is vibrating.
So there's some kind
of maybe motion.
I'll just kind of
indicate like this
just that this is kind
of shaking and vibrating
and coming together.
And of course,
there's also mucus
and other liquids that are
here lining all these things.
And when those folds
come close together,
they touch each other, and they
can pull apart and again form
these filaments that can
break up and generate
droplets that will be
emitted of different sizes.
Now, one thing to notice
is the length scale,
so the mouth when it's opening
might have a length scale
obviously on the order of maybe
centimeters but more likely
millimeters in the regions
where there could actually
be emissions of droplets.
If we look at the vocal
cords, that scale is also
going to be millimeters, but
when the vocal cords really
come together and
pull apart, we might
be looking at scales that
are much smaller than that.
So some of these filaments
that are breaking up
could be significantly
smaller, and so
vocalization may lead to
droplets that are quite a bit
smaller.
In fact, in the case of the
mouth, as I just mentioned,
the sort of length scale might
be of order of millimeters
for the filaments
that are breaking up.
And the size of the
droplets R might
be on the order of 10 to
100 microns or even bigger,
actually.
In fact, it can even
go up to-- well,
maybe not quite millimeters, but
in the case of, let's say when
you're coughing or spitting,
certainly you are spitting out
millimeters, but
it could be even--
maybe I'll put even
here 1 millimeter
as sort of a kind of upper
bound on the types of droplets
that you could be emitting.
In the case of the voicebox, our
length scale's a bit smaller.
It might be on the order
more like of 100 microns
for these filaments
that are breaking up.
And the radius of droplets
that you're going to form
are going to be
smaller, and they
might be ranging
more in the 1 to 10
micron range or
possibly larger, again,
depending on the details.
If you're coughing and
there's a lot of mucus here,
certainly you could get maybe
larger than that as well.
So breakup of filaments
is a primary mechanism
of drop formation, especially
in the upper respiratory tract.
Now what about in the
lower respiratory tract?
So that's really
referring to your lungs.
So in the lower
respiratory tract,
there is significant
evidence and also at least
qualitative theories
and to some extent
quantitative theories showing
that the main mechanism is not
so much the breakup of
filaments in a flow,
but rather the bursting
of filaments of mucus
but in much smaller
domains, where it's not
so much that the fluid is
whipping by and breaking apart
the droplets, but it's simply
breaking up due to surface
tension.
Just that it's this
instability kind
of like in a dripping faucet
or a stream of liquid when you
start to stretch it out and
let surface tension act,
it kind of squeezes
down, eventually
wants to make droplets.
So that's kind of the
rupture of a film.
Under surface tension, it's
more likely to be the mechanism.
And so this is kind of
maybe more generally
can be thought of as an
elastocapillarity instability
of mucosal films,
specifically in the deepest
part of the lungs and
in the smallest passages
during during inhaling
in the bronchioles
and also, to some
extent, in the alveola.
During inhaling, that's when
the breakup is happening,
and then any droplets
that are creating,
some may deposit on the walls
of the respiratory tract,
but some fraction of them
will be swept back out again.
So let me explain this a
little bit more detail.
I should also mention
this mechanism is also
referred to as the bronchial
film burst hypothesis.
And I say it's a hypothesis
because despite the fact
that there's been a lot
of study of the droplets
that are produced by
different forms of respiration
and some theoretical
modeling, it's
difficult to actually observe
this process occurring
in the body.
And so it's still--
it's a hypothesis that
people are still studying.
So what we're
thinking of here is
if we zoom in to a bronchiole,
which is a passage that looks
maybe something like this,
it's like basically it's
a flexible tube.
And the smallest
ones of these now
are getting down to the
scale of 100 microns or so.
So it is kind of like a
typical length scale here of,
let's say for the radius,
might be 100 microns or less.
And these of course are
lined with mucus as well.
And in some places,
there's a bridge.
So it's kind of like there's
almost like bubbles of air
with sort of little
bridges of mucus.
In fact, you may actually
have even some places
where the passage after exhale
has completely collapsed.
And so maybe some parts
of it are touching.
Others are not touching.
But there's kind of these little
bridges of liquid or films,
bronchial films that are kind of
extending across at least part
or even all of those channels.
Now, imagine we start
in this situation,
and we start inhaling.
And let's just say this is
the direction of inhaling.
Let's imagine that
the alveola, which
is kind of on the end
of this tube, and so
let's see what happens
if we start inhaling.
So for inhaling, then
the air is flowing in.
And so the first
thing that happens
is that these bubbles are
going to start essentially--
this film is essentially
going to be pushed.
As that liquid is being pushed,
we have some flows occurring.
There's some recirculation
flows in there.
Also, there's interaction with
the elastic or stretchy walls,
which are soft,
of the bronchiole,
and so it can expand.
So if you go to
the next step, you
may find as you continue
inhaling that now this tube has
expanded a bit.
So it might look more like this.
And then this, to
some extent, this film
would start to get stretched.
And then at some point, as
this thing is trying to open,
and also it's under some
flow, but it's going to burst.
And this bursting again
is not quite the same
as this situation because
the flows are much slower.
So here, these flows are often
at so-called high Reynolds
number, as we'll talk
about later in this class.
High Reynolds number refers
to the tendency of the flow
to become unstable and for
inertial effects and momentum
of fluid to become important.
At the scale of the mouth or the
nose or even the vocal cords,
there can be significant
inertial effects and very
complex flows.
On the other hand,
when we get down
to the smallest
channels in the lungs,
and especially
when we reach kind
of the dead end, these
sort of the alveolas, which
is basically a bunch
of little sacs,
they're kind of at the end here,
then it's kind of a dead end.
There can't be any like very
fast flow through that system.
And so it's actually a low
Reynolds number situation.
So we're not talking about
turbulent flows or sprays
of liquid at high
Reynolds number.
Instead, we're
talking about films
that are getting stretched out,
and then they simply break up
under the effect of
capilarity, which
refers to surface tension.
So basically, when
you expose a surface
and stretch out a
liquid film, it just
tends to break up into
little droplets, basically
in order to minimize its energy.
So what we'll see
here is that maybe one
of these films over
here has already
burst and will lead
to some droplets that
are being created.
So this bursting of the film
is what leads to the droplets.
And when you're
inhaling, those get swept
a little further downstream.
Some of them may deposit on the
walls and go back into the film
and coalesce into the
film, but others will
remain suspended in the air.
And now when you
exhale, you start
pushing back the other way.
The tube is more
open now, and we
may have a situation
like this where there's
no more sort of
spanning films left,
but there's some fraction
of these droplets.
A few of them may have deposited
and coalesced on the surfaces,
but they're going to start
getting blown out the other way
now.
And so these are the droplet
emissions right here.
I'll just say it'll
eventually do that.
So some fraction of these
will make it all the way out.
Of course, those droplets
can deposit anywhere
in the respiratory tract.
In fact, some of them, if you're
breathing through your nose,
may end up getting caught
in your nose, actually.
And so there's an
exchange of fluids
between the different parts
of the respiratory tract,
but some fraction of those
droplets will get out.
And then ultimately, when
you're finished exhaling,
now the pressure is released.
And this tube kind of relaxes
back to its original state
where there's some mucus here
and there's some places maybe
where it's closed and there's
these possibly spanning films
in some places where
it's almost touching.
So these are some of
the basic processes
by which droplets are emitted.
As you can see by the range
of different processes
that are possible in
the human physiology
that we've just
described, we can
see there's a range
of droplet sizes
that will depend on the
respiratory activity.
Are you breathing lightly
because you're sleeping?
Are you breathing
heavily at high speeds
because you're exercising?
Are you vocalizing
and generating
droplets in a different
way in the larynx?
All those activities
play a role.
And also there are variations
between individuals.
And finally, if a person is
sick and all these fluids
I've sketched here as mucus
contain pathogens such as virus
or bacteria, then of course
the degree of infection,
the viral load or the
total amount of pathogen,
the total amount of
bacteria plays a role
as well in sort
of how infectious
the emissions are
from breathing.
But these are some of
the basic principles.
And now we'll move on to ask,
what happens to those droplets
after they leave the mouth
of the infected person?